vous l'avez pas mis en place en 2020
vous attendez aujourd'hui pourquoi on
réagit toujours quand il y a un scandale
il y a quand même des travaux qui ont
été amorcés depuis plusieurs mois avec
le comité indépendant du programme
d'aide aux joueurs vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure qui n'avait jamais
indemnisé quelqu'un hors cours pour lier
à une initiation est-ce que ça a déjà
été fait dans d'autres cas oui mais vous
ne révéler l'équipe qui est visée
[Musique]
vous êtes aussi sincèrement
scabreuse douteuse l'auber de la ligne
qui sont montés à votre connaissance
depuis que vous êtes là et dans les
dernières années l'année dernière année
non quand on a eu quand elle était mis
au courant de quelque chose est
intervenu immédiatement
le député libéral Enrico Chiconi est le
député de Québec solidaire Vincent
Marisa ont tous deux participé à ces
audiences sur la violence dans les
initiations donc ils ont pu poser comme
vous l'avez vu leurs questions
directement à gilles-courtaud on a aussi
invité le député pecquis Pascal Bérubé
son agenda malheureusement ne lui
permettait pas d'être avec nous ce soir
donc on poursuit la discussion avec nos
deux prochains invités monsieur Marissal
monsieur gigogney bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir
Monsieur Marisol c'est vous qui avez
demandé que Monsieur Courtot vienne
s'expliquer répondre aux questions des
élus alors c'est le résultat qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui il dit qu'aucun incident
n'avait été porté à sa connaissance en
fait il dit il y a pas eu d'événements
relatifs aux initiations portaient à sa
connaissance il reconnaît quand même une
culture du silence il dit que c'est
possible qu'il y a eu des événements
mais pas des plaintes est-ce que la
réponse pour vous était satisfaisante
il a utilisé les mots il y a pas eu
d'événements similaires à ce qu'on a lu
dans l'article et vous aviez Martin
luxaire il y a quelques minutes alors
similaire non et c'est une bonne
nouvelle en soi parce que c'était assez
scabreux et assez révoltant cela dit il
y a pas eu de plainte peut-être
notamment parce que il y a la culture du
silence dont parle monsieur Courtot et
il le dit clairement il le dit un moment
donné la porte du vestiaire se ferme et
c'est la fin des émissions pour nous on
sait plus rien et puis quand vous
regardez le processus de plainte il est
tellement mal foutu il est tellement pas
indépendant il n'assure tellement pas la
probité du processus pour les victimes
je fais assez étonné que des victimes se
plient à ça tandis que le système
processus dit en ce moment c'est qu'un
jeune qui sentirait léger ou agresser
doit appeler la Ligue pour pour porter
plainte avec un numéro de téléphone
alors imaginez directement à la Ligue
qui protège les gens ou alors encore
mieux dans le procédé la procédure on
dit mais commencez donc par en parler
avec votre agresseur il me semble qu'un
jeune de 17 ans qui se fait agressé par
son coach ou qui se fait humilier par
son poche va le prendre dans un petit
coin après la pratique pour dire ICO
j'aime pas ce que tu me fais ça pas de
sens c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne donc et ça expliquerait
finalement que cette règle du silence
perdue
monsieur Courtot le conçoit clair et il
me dit le sincèrement alors on va le
prendre mais il y a du travail à faire
bon mais si tu connais vous voulez
réagir aussi à ça bien entendu ce
Courtault il le dit les initiations de
toute façon elles sont interdites un
petit peu comme si ce problème là
d'initiations ben c'est réglé ils n'ont
pas le droit à vos enfants c'est quoi de
cette réponse là effectivement c'est
toujours facile de dire de d'interdire
une pratique c'est la même chose avec
les fameux codes de conduite où on fait
signer des feuilles à des parents on
fait ses feuilles à des joueurs et on
leur dit le voici un code de conduite
vous l'avez signé vous devez le
respecter mais en même temps qui il va
le faire respecter si on a enfin ce
règlement-là tantôt vous avez mentionné
la culture du silence c'est vrai qu'une
culture du silence j'y crois mais en
même temps moi je crois ce qui est
encore pire dans tout ça c'est que là je
reviens à mon époque à moi là c'était
même pas une culture du silence c'était
la normalité c'était normal de passer à
travers les initiations c'était normal
que l'année suivante faisait partie du
groupe qu'initiait les nouvelles recrues
et ça allait comme ça ainsi de suite
briser l'omerta briser silence si on dit
aux joueurs on les encadre bien puis il
y a des personnes de confiance ils vont
parler mais quand ça devient normal ça
devient une culture ça c'est pas mal
plus difficile
les gens ils sont plus heureux
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 20 ans en laissant
entendre finalement que ça avait évolué
depuis votre époque finalement monsieur
Chiconi est-ce que vous y croyez est-ce
que ça a changé tant que ça je pense que
oui je pense que ça a changé maintenant
aujourd'hui là ce qu'on entend ce qu'on
a lu sur la plume de Martin laclasse
c'est c'est c'est scandaleux ce qu'on
nous lu là maintenant est-ce qu'on je
suis prêt à dire que c'est comme ça à
l'entièreté de tous les clubs de l'île
canadienne de hockey je peux prêt à dire
ça mais en même temps je suis prêt à
dire qu'au lieu plus de programme plus
de mesures en place pour s'assurer que
ces choses là n'arrivent pas mais en
même temps quand on amène une gang de
jeunes ensemble c'est pas seulement dans
dans le sport en général je dirais même
aussi si on voit ce qui s'est passé avec
mes guilde le basketball c'était des
jeunes filles également souvent quand on
réunit des jeunes ensemble un peu ester
intellectuel va descendre le fait de
groupe finalement et l'adolescence
peut-être on pourrait mettre ça ensemble
là bon Vincent narissal le code du
vestiaire qu'est-ce que vous y avez
compris parce que Monsieur Courtot il
propose ça comme solution
nous dit aussi dans la même phrase que
quand la porte se ferme du vestiaire il
y a pas vraiment de contrôle puis il
peut pas vraiment savoir ce qui se passe
là il souhaiterait seulement qu'il y ait
un code on l'a pas vu le code c'est une
intention pour le moment je suggérait à
la ligne de hockey junior majeur de
revoir son processus de plainte de 1 de
2 je suggérais à la Ligue de hockey
junior majeur du Québec de voir
qu'est-ce que Megel a fait après
l'incident football de 2005 il y avait
eu un grave grave problème aussi
d'initiation mais qu'elle avait fait une
ou deux il avait fermé le programme
national pendant un ancien ce qui était
mal passé à l'époque ça avait mal passé
mais ils l'ont fait pareil mais Gilles a
fait une liste et puis si tu connais le
signe de ce qu'il faut pas faire de ce
qui est interdit fait quand c'est pas
interdit énormément c'est permis ou en
tout cas certains vont se le dire sauf
que quand c'est écrit noir sur blanc
vous le savez que si vous traversez
cette ligne là vous êtes en infraction
mais il y a de sol dans la ligue de
hockey générale majeure en ce moment
c'est ce sont des intentions et ce matin
ce matin comme par hasard la Ligue de
hockey arrive avec toutes sortes de
nouvelles mesures un bouquet de
nouvelles mesures que pousser la nuit
dernière probablement parce que
j'imagine mais effectivement il a fallu
qu'il y a une crise puis qu'on les
convoque pour que le tout d'un coup ils
veulent montrer patte blanche
avec Monsieur Courtot quand il est
arrivé justement avec en présentant
c'est solution en fait Martin Leclerc le
disait juste avant finalement
essentiellement vous lui avez dit mais
là vous en avez des solutions mais vous
les connaissez déjà depuis quelques
années pourquoi vous les avez pas
appliqués plutôt est-ce que sa réponse
vous assemblez satisfaisante vous
comprenez que moi depuis enfin mon
historique là depuis 2000 que j'ai pris
ma retraite que j'ai commencé à
travailler au niveau du développement et
du soutien des jeunes à la Légion
majeure du Québec et j'ai eu mes démêler
avec les gens majeur du Québec là
souvent vous parliez Martin Leclerc
parler de la politique antidopage moi je
me rappelle l'époque là 2003 j'avais
appelé justement la Ligue junior je leur
avais dit il y avait un problème de
consommation au niveau des joies parce
que les gens m'avaient témoigné des
policiers entre eux n'avaient témoigné
qui a certains joueurs plusieurs joueurs
même prenaient des substances alors moi
j'avais averti la Ligue la Ligue est
décidé de rien faire alors moi j'ai pris
les choses en main j'ai fait sauter la
planète hockey et par la suite deux
trois mois plus tard ils ont appliqué la
politique antidopage c'est ce que je
disais pendant la commission aujourd'hui
pendant les travaux pourquoi toujours
attendre qu'un scandale avant qu'on
qu'on mette des programmes ou qu'on
avance justement avec des mesures parce
que depuis 2020 je répète 2020 le
novembre 2020 il y avait un repas le
rapport entre les mains il y aurait pu
justement avoir le code de vestiaire en
2020 donc il réagit seulement une fois
que la pression est rendue tellement
insoutenable qu'ils ont pas le choix de
bouger c'est ce que vous dites là c'est
toujours cette espèce de mode passive et
encore aujourd'hui on dit mais ça va
être effectif pour l'année 2023 2024 je
voyais non qui vient de vivre ce Canada
on sait ce qui arrive on a un rapport
pourquoi vous ne mettez pas en place
immédiatement pas obligé d'attendre la
prochaine saison de faire ça
il faut toujours que ça explose pour que
le finalement on monte à blanche et
encore encore il y a des joueurs
notamment à donne Kennedy à qui on avait
demandé un rapport avec Madame Sauvageau
puis l'ancien Premier ministre Théo du
nouveau brandeux il en fait le rapport
ce rapport-là il dit notamment que le
problème est systémique c'était pour la
Ligue canadienne de hockey mais je
signale ici là que la Ligue de hockey
junior fait partie de cette ligue là
avec l'Ontario puis l'Ouest canadien et
on fait un rapport disant qu'il y a 10%
des joueurs qui leur ont dit j'ai subi
des CV de du harcèlement et des
agressions il y a 25% qui ont dit moi
j'ai déjà été témoin de ça pourtant ce
rapport-là il a disparu de la
circulation pendant 14 mois puis quand
ils ont été obligés de leur mettre sur
la place publique ils l'ont édulcorer un
demandant un film Toronto le
dansvelopper ça pour noyer le poisson
alors finalement c'est pas qu'une
culture du silence c'est une culture de
manque de transparence d'un peu ce que
vous êtes en train de dire aussi Vincent
Larissa d'ailleurs votre persil a émis
un communiqué et on vous cite dans le
communiqué où on dit ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui c'est la pointe de l'iceberg
ça prendrait une autre journée de
commission c'est ce que vous demandez
vous voulez que ça se prononce
au moins une autre journée moi
j'aimerais qu'on voit que justement le
seul donne Kennedy et d'autres là on
nous a parlé aujourd'hui de psychologue
du sport ça c'est mes guilde qui nous a
parlé de ce serait très curieux de les
entendre pourquoi pas la ministre
Isabelle Charrey
une autre journée ou peut-être plusieurs
oh non moi je demande pas mal plus puis
j'en ai parlé avec avec Vincent ou
monsieur marxel par des mois
pardonnez-moi moi j'ai dit là on a fait
un premier pas mais c'est pas vrai qu'on
va arrêter c'est pas vrai qu'on va faire
un show de Boucan politique juste pour
dire qu'on a réagi un scandale et on a
fait un premier pas aujourd'hui il faut
attendre d'autres groupes et même
peut-être d'avoir une commission
itinéraire pour aller sur le terrain
voir ce qui se passe mais avoir un suivi
année après année avec ses gros plats
Enrico je connais Vincent Marisol merci
à vous deux merci merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici